اذا ما تحدثنا عن مجريات ليله امس بعد شن
قوات الاحتلال وطائرات الاحتلال عشرات
الغارات الاسرائيليه على عده بنايات سكنيه
في مدينه غزه حتى هذه اللحظه وصل الى
مستشفى الشفاء 17 شهيدا مجهولي الهويه قد
يتكرر السيناريو دفن شهداء مجهولي الهويه
داخل مستشفى الشفاء للمره الثانيه واذا ما
تحدثنا عن العمليه العسكريه واينما توجهت
قوات الاحتلال قوات الاحتلال بدات عمليتها
العسكريه دخولا من منطقه بهلول الواقعه في
حي الشيخ رضوان شمال منطقه مدينه غزه
بالاضافه مرورا بحي النصر او شارع النصر
الرئيسي وصولا الى مفترق العائلات
بالاضافه الى ذلك من الجهه الجنوبيه دخلت
منطقه تله الهواء مرورا بمنطقه الجامعات
ثم ايضا الى منطقه الاتصالات والتقت
الدبابات في تلك المنطقه حتى اصبح هذاه
المنطقه هي محور تواجد قوات الاحتلال بشكل
كثيف قوات الاحتلال دمرت الكثير من
المباني واطلقت مئات الرصاصات باتجاه
المنازل والبنايات السكنيه بالاضافه الى
افاده بع بعض المواطنين ان قوات الاحتلال
عملت على تفتيش بعض المنازل في منطقه حي
النصر يبدو ان قوات الاحتلال مهدت لهذه
العمليه بالقصف المتواصل في قبل دخولها
بالاضافه الى ذلك قوات الاحتلال قصفت
اسعافي في منطقه ايطاليانو او مطعم
ايطاليانو الذي قصف فيما قبل قرب مستشفى
الشفاء وهذه الاسعافات تم انتشال قبل
لحظات من الخدمات الطبيه عنصر يتبع
للخدمات الطبيه كان متواجد داخل هذه
الاسعافات في حين ان الطواقم الطبيه لا
تجد او لم تجد باقي الطواقم الطبيه التي
كانت تتواجد داخل هذه اسعافات اما
بالانتقال الى الوضع الان داخل مجمع
الشفاء ومحيط مجمع الشفاء قوات الاحتلال
تتمركز بشكل كثيف جدا في المنطقه الجنوبيه
لمجمع الشفاء الطبي منطقه دوار حيدر
ومنطقه الاتصالات ومنطقه دوار انصار هذه
المنطقه الواقعه في الجهه الجنوبيه
الغربيه لمستشفى الشفاء عشرات القذائف
الصاروخيه تطلق باتجاه محيط مستشفى الشفاء
بالتحديد في المنطقه الجنوبيه بالاضافه
الى اطلاق الكثير من الرصاصات الكثير من
العائلات نزحت من هذه المنطقه توجها الى
مستشفى الشفاء بالاضافه الى ذلك الكثير من
العائلات نزحت من داخل مستشفى الشفاء بسبب
الوضع الخطير والخطوره التي التي باتت
واضحه على حياه المواطنين بالاضافه الى
ذلك الكثير من الاطباء نزحوا من تلك
المنطقه هروبا من القصف والموت الاسرائيلي
المتواصل الان بات مستشفى الشفاء في حاله
كارثيه توقفت اقسام العمليات توقف قسم
الطوارئ بشكل شبه كامل الان كل من يصل
مصابا الى داخل مستشفى الشفاء لا يتعامل
معه الا فئه محدوده من الاطباء الذين بقوا
داخل المجمع هم من يمارسون عملهم في حين
ان الكثير نزحوا هربا وخوفا من القصف
الاسرائيلي المتواصل الحاله الصحيه باتت
كارثيه يبدو ان قوات الاحتلال تعيد اسقاط
ما تم ترميمه من وزاره الصحه على مدار
ايام متواصله قرابه ال 50 يوم عملت وزاره
الصحه على تمير ترميم ما دمرته قوات
الاحتلال من تشغيل غرف عمليات من من تشغيل
قسم الكلى الوحيد المتواجد في شمال قطاع
غزه الذي بات يعمل يوما بعد يوم على انقاذ
حياه المرضى بات حي ايضا وعمل قسم بنك
الدم الذي انقذ حياه الكثير من المرضى
بسحب وحدات الدم واعاده تشغيل هذا القسم
بشكل فعلي الان مستشفى الشفاء يعمل بشكل
جزئي بعد الحاله الصعبه والخطوره ال التي
باتت واضحه على مستشفى الشفاء في حين ان
قوات الاحتلال تومئ وتلمح كثيرا على
المناطق الغربيه مثل منطقه مستشفى الشفاء
المناطق الغربيه التي تتواجد بها من مدينه
غزه مختلف المناطق سواء حي الشيخ رضوان او
مختلف المناطق الغربيه قوات الاحتلال تلمح
وتجري اتصالات على الكثير من المواطنين
وايضا صفحات جيش الاحتلال نشرت عن تلك
المناطق يبدو ان قوات الاحتلال تمهد
لعمليه عسكريه جديده في تلك المنطقه حتى
اللحظه نحن نتابع التطورات عن قرب وعن كثف
متواجدين داخل مجمع الشفاء الطبي على
الرغم من الخطر المباشر الذي بات يهدد هذا
المجمع اتمنى لكم السلامه اى